the lactose mihika cheese dairy is a
family business every week it produces
40 tons of cheese for the Mexican market
and every week the company uses 40,000
litres of hot water there has to be at a
temperature of at least 70 degrees
Celsius to kill off germs and to heat it
the cheese maker uses nearly 100,000
liters of liquid gas the tanks are kept
up on the roof along with a new solar
technology which is already saving him
money
and literacy and dinero up to now we
were paying eighty thousand Mexican
pesos a month for gas that's around
three thousand seven hundred euros now
it's 30% less but the technology itself
didn't come cheap the solar heating
facility on the roof measures a hundred
and twenty square meters and cost the
equivalent of seventy five thousand
euros now the water is warm directly by
the Sun but there's still room for
improvement which is why the head of
technology at inventive power is here
they manufacture the solar collector the
biggest challenge is to integrate the
heat from the solar collectors into the
conventional processes of the factory
normally companies work with steam
that's generated using fossil fuels it's
hard to get customers to realize that
they can get the same effect with the
solar system as with a conventional
boiler you get the company's two
founders are not just interested in
sales
they're both ambitious engineers whose
aim is to improve the dearies energy
efficiency where's the Gallup
reinforcement Dracula media every
project is unique it takes time to
optimize the businesses and to make a
real difference to the energy
consumption and costs and of course
still dinner here
550 kilometers to the east is Mexico
City home to a population of 20 million
despite the abundant sunshine in this
part of the world
solar power isn't big business and Homer
here is on his way to a trade fair or 3
to be precise all in one place one of
them is into solar Mexico Mejia is here
to look around and check out the
competition and also to rustle up new
business his company inventive power has
its own stand one of the main targets to
be here in the expo of course is that
visitors and know about our technology
that this type of technology is working
now on more than 100 companies in Mexico
so we have to convince visitors that
this is a real technology that you can
install right away but industrial
applications for solar thermal
technology remain a niche market
Marysol oropesa is planning to change
that with support from a German
government she's raising the profile of
solar thermal technology across the
country yeah there is a lack of
awareness there are many people who
still don't know that you can use solar
energy to heat up water for instance
many people think you can use solar
energy just to get power get electricity
so we need to educate people about this
other type of application the company
inventive power was founded in 2010 it's
built 60 solar thermal plants which
reduce carbon emissions by 4,000 tons a
year the principle is simple
this is the solar collector which has a
parabolic shape all the energy that
catches on the surface is reflected into
this receiver and it's high temperature
generates dirt so when the water passes
inside the tube absorbs the heat from
the Sun at very high temperature the
collector has to be precisely positioned
yeah the collector in order to catch
most of the energy has to track the Sun
during the day to do that we have the
power trackerpro this is an electronic
bird that has sensors peripherals and
different components to make the
intelligence of solar tracking of the
products the dairy is one of the
company's flagship projects Ono
Rigoberto mihika is hoping to see a
return on his investment within the next
five years the environmental rewards
will be immediate
you